Zooming back in to what is going on within a given operating system, we already
know that the process address space for an application is an illusion in the
sense that the virtual memory space of this process is contiguous, but in terms
of physical memory, they are not contiguous.
And the page table data structure that the
operating system maintains, on behalf of the processes.
Is the one that supports this illusion so
far as this process is concerned. By mapping
the virtual page number of the process, using
the page table for this particular process into
the physical page number, where a particular virtual
page may be contained in physical memory. This
is a setting in a non-virtualized operating system.
So the page table serves as the broker to convert a virtual page number to a
physical page number. In a virtualized setting, we
have another level of indirection, that is this
physical page number of the operating system has
to be mapped to the machine memory or
the machine page numbers. We'll call the pages
in the machine memory, which is the real thing,
as MPN, short for Machine Page Numbers. And
this goes from zero through some max, which
is the total memory capacity that you have
in your hardware. This data structure, the page table,
is a traditional page table, that gives a
mapping between virtual page number and the physical
page number. And this is a traditional page
table. The mapping between the physical page number and
the machine page number, that is PPN to MPN mapping, is kept
in another page table, which is called shadow page table,
S-PT. So now, in a virtualized setting, there's a two-step
translation process to go from VPN to MPN. The
page table maintained by the guest operating system is the one
that translates VPN to PPN and then there is this additional page table called a
shadow page table that converts the PPN
to MPN. That brings up an interesting question.